TOE SUMMIT WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS THE U.S. PERMANENT
REPRESENTATIVE TO NATO
AMBASSADOR JULIANNE SMITH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
AMBASSADOR, FOR JOINING ME.
LET'S START WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S COMMENT YESTERDAY, THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN CANNOT REMAIN IN
POWER.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID QUICKLY
THAT HE WAS NOT DISCUSSING
PUTIN'S POWER IN RUSSIA OR
REGIME CHANGE.
WAS THAT COMMENT A MISTAKE?
>> WELL, LOOK, THE PRESIDENT HAD
SPENT THE DAY VISITING WITH
UKRAINIAN REFUGEES.
HE WENT TO THE NATIONAL STADIUM
IN WARSAW AND LITERALLY MET WITH
HUNDREDS OF UKRAINIANS.
HE HEARD THEIR HEROIC STORIES AS
THEY WERE FLEEING UKRAINE IN THE
WAKE OF RUSSIA'S BRUTAL WAR IN
UKRAINE.
IN THE MOMENT, I THINK THAT WAS
A PRINCIPLED HUMAN REACTION TO
THE STORIES THAT HE HAD HEARD
THAT DAY, BUT NO, AS YOU HEARD
FROM SECRETARY BLINKEN AND
OTHERS, THE U.S. DOES NOT HAVE A
POLICY OF REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA.
FULL STOP.
>> HAVING SAID WHAT YOU SAID,
LISTENING TO THE PRESIDENT, HE
SOUNDED PRETTY UNAMBIGUOUS.
"THIS MAN CANNOT REMAIN IN
POWER."
ARE YOU CONCERNED BY WALKING
BACK THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENT,
YOU AND OTHER ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS MAY BE UNDERMINING HIM
ON THE WORLD STAGE AT A REALLY
CRITICAL MOMENT?
>> I THINK WE ALL FEEL GREAT
ABLED HOW THE LAST COUPLE DAYS
HAVE GONE.
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO GET THE
PRESIDENT HERE TO EUROPE.
HE HAD SEVERAL IMPORTANT
MEETINGS IN BRUSSELS WITH NATO
LEADERS, WITH THE G7, WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR HIM TO GO
TO POLAND.
HE VISITED A CITY CLOSE TO THE
BORDER WITH UKRAINE.
HE WAS ABLE TO JOIN A MEETING
WITH THE UKRAINIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER AND DEFENSE MINISTER.
HE WAS ABLE TO SIT DOWN WITH
PRESIDENT DUDA AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT POLAND IS DOING AT THIS
MOMENT, LITERALLY TAKING
MILLIONS OF REFUGEES INTO THEIR
COUNTRY.
THIS WEEKEND HAS BEEN
REMARKABLE, IT'S BEEN HISTORIC.
I THOUGHT THE SPEECH WAS
COMPLETELY PITCH PERFECT.
I THINK THIS WILL SET US ON A
GOOD COURSE FOR CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT THE ALLIES, SUPPORT
UKRAINIANS AND APPLY PRESSURE ON
RUSSIA TO GET THEM TO STOP THIS
WAR.
>> I WANT TO MOVE ON, BUT JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME MURKINESS
OUT THERE, YOU SAID THE U.S.
POLICY IS NOT REGIME CHANGE,
FULL STOP.
DOES THAT MEAN THE U.S. BELIEVES
PUTIN SHOULD BE IN POWER?
>> I THINK WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT
WE ARE NOT PURSUING A POLICY OF
REGIME CHANGE, BUT I THINK THE
FULL ADMINISTRATION, THE
PRESIDENT INCLUDED, BELIEVES
THAT WE CANNOT EMPOWER PUTIN
RIGHT NOW TO WAGE WAR IN UKRAINE
OR PURSUE THESE ACTS OF
AGGRESSION.
>> THE RUSSIANS ARE PUBLICLY
SUGGESTING THEY'RE CHANGING
THEIR FOCUS TO A MORE LIMITED
GOAL IN ONLY THE DONBAS REGION.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY SIGNS THAT
THIS ACTUALLY COULD BE
HAPPENING?
>> SO WE WILL MONITOR THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
ARE SHIFTING TACTICS.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE EVIDENCE
OF THAT QUITE YET.
BUT WHAT WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE OF
IS THE FACT THAT THE RUSSIANS
HAVE NOT SUCCEEDED IN THEIR
ORIGINAL AIMS, AND THAT WAS, AS
YOU WELL KNOW, TO TAKE KYIV IN
JUST A COUPLE OF DAYS.
WE'RE NOW AT THE ONE-MONTH POINT
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE NOT PERFORMING AS
ANTICIPATED AND THIS HAS NOT
GONE AS PLANNED.
SO BECAUSE OF THAT, I THINK
RUSSIA IS REASSESSING AND
THEY'VE INDICATED THEY'RE GOING
TO ALTER THEIR TACTICS.
LET'S GIVE IT SOME TIME.
THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS, THE UNITED
STATES WORKING CLOSELY WITH
ALLIES AND THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT WILL BE LOOKING FOR
EVIDENCE OF THIS SHIFT.
>> REASSESSING, COULD THAT BE
LOOKING FOR AN OFF-RAMP FOR THE
WAR TO END?
>> WELL, WE'VE MADE CLEAR FROM
DAY ONE THAT WE WANT PUTIN TO
STOP THIS WAR IN UKRAINE, AND WE
GAVE HIM MANY OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE WEEKS LEADING UP TO FEBRUARY
24th WHEN THEY WENT IN.
AS YOU'LL REMEMBER, WE ACTUALLY
MET WITH THE RUSSIANS
BILATERALLY.
WE MET WITH THE RUSSIANS AT NATO
HEADQUARTERS AND AT THE OSCE.
SADLY PUTIN OPTED FOR ANOTHER
PATH, ANOTHER PATH OF
AGGRESSION.
AND EVER THINS THAT DAY, SINCE
FEBRUARY 24th, WE'VE BEEN
APPLYING PRESSURE ON THEM TO
STOP THE WAR.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN, AS YOU WELL
KNOW, WAS WITH YOU IN BRUSSELS
THIS WEEK AT AN EMERGENCY NATO
SUMMIT.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT A
TOP ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY SAID SPEAKING ABOUT
THAT SUMMIT.
>> WE ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED, IF
I'M HONEST.
WE WOULD EXPECT MORE BRAVERY,
EXPECTED SOME BOLD DECISIONS.
THE ALLIES ARE TAKING DECISIONS
AS IF THEY'RE NO WORTH --
>> HE WENT ON TO SAY NATO'S
RESPONSE WAS, QUOTE,
APPEASEMENT.
AS THE U.S. AMBASSADOR TO NATO,
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE?
>> WELL, THIS HAS BEEN A
REMARKABLE MOMENT IN NATO'S
HISTORY.
WE CAME TOGETHER QUICKLY, THE
SAME DAY RUSSIA WENT INTO
UKRAINE, WE HAD AN EMERGENCY
SESSION.
WE ACTIVATED PLANS TO MOVE
FORCES INTO EASTERN EUROPE.
WE ALSO IMMEDIATELY STARTED
PROVIDING LETHAL ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINE.
UNITED STATES SINCE JANUARY OF
THE LAST YEAR HAS PROVIDED $2
BILLION OF LETHAL AS ASSISTANCE
TO UKRAINE.
WE OR WORKING WITH THEM EACH AND
EVERY WEEK TO DETERMINE HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HELP THEM WITH
ANTI AIR ASSETS, ANTI ARMOR.
WE'VE OFFERED STINGERS, PROVIDED
JAVELINS AND MANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE NATO ALLIANCE ARE DOING
THE SAME THING.
I THINK ABOUT TWO-THIRDS OF THE
NATO ALLIANCE ARE NOW PROVIDING
LETHAL ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE.
EVERY ALLY IS MAKING A
DISTRIBUTION.
SOME ARE PROVIDING HUMANITARIAN
SUPPORT.
SOME ARE PROVIDING LETHAL.
MOST ARE DOING BOTH.
>> YOU'VE HEARD, I'M SURE,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAY JUST
THIS WEEKEND THAT HE WANTS FROM
NATO ONLY 1% OF WHAT IT HAS IN
TANKS AND PLANES TO GO TO
UKRAINE.
HE SAID YOU HAVE THOUSANDS OF
FIGHTER JETS, BUT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN GIVEN ONE YET.
SO YES OR NO, WILL NATO GIVE
UKRAINE WHAT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
IS ASKING FOR?
>> WELL, THIS IS AN EVOLVING
CONVERSATION.
WE'VE SPOKEN WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY MANY TIMES IN RECENT
WEEKS.
WE'VE HEARD THEIR REQUESTS FOR
ASSISTANCE.
IN MANY CASES WE'VE DELIVERED
THOSE ANTI-AIRCRAFT, ANTI-ARMOR
CAPABILITIES.
WE'RE ASSESSING THE AIR DEFENSE
NEEDS.
THE ANSWER IS NO, IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SOVIET-ERA
JETS, THE UNITED STATES DECIDED
THE PARTICULAR PROPOSAL PUT
FORWARD BY POLAND IS UNTENABLE.
HONESTLY, IF ANY NATO ALLY
WANTED TO PROVIDE THOSE TYPES OF
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT, THE FIGHTER
JETS, THE MIGS, THAT IS A
SOVEREIGN DECISION.
THEY CAN TAKE THAT SOVEREIGN
DECISION.
RIGHT NOW THE UNITED STATES IS
VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON THEIR AIR
DEFENSE NEEDS AND WERE
DELIVERING MULTIPLE CAPABILITIES
TO TRY AND ADDRESS THOSE
REQUIREMENTS.
>> HE WAS REALLY SPECIFIC SAYING
1% OF NATO'S CAPABILITY.
IS THAT TENABLE?
>> WELL, I'D HAVE TO DO THE MATH
ON WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN PROVIDED.
AS I STATED, MOST NATO ALLIES
ARE PROVIDING SITUATION STANCE
INCLUDING ALLIES THAT HAVE HAD
LONGSTANDING POLICIES NOT TO DO
SO.
WE'VE SEEN A MAJOR CHANGE IN
EUROPE WITH MANY ALLIES COMING
FORWARD.
WE'D HAVE TO GO AHEAD AND COUNT
UP WHAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO DATE,
WHAT'S IN TRAIN AND WHAT ALLIES
ARE THINKING ABOUT TO REALLY
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
FITS THAT PARTICULAR
CALCULATION.
BUT I THINK HONESTLY WHAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE IS THAT NATO
ALLIES ARE COMING FORWARD AND
OFFERING THE CAPABILITIES THAT
UKRAINE IS SEEKING AND THEY'RE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS RAISING
NEW CONCERNS ABOUT CYBERATTACKS.
HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT ARTICLE 5
IS A, QUOTE, SACRED COMMITMENT.
HOW DOES THE U.S. UNDERSTAND
ARTICLE 5 OF THE NATO CHARTER?
DO YOU SEE IT TO INCLUDE A
CYBERATTACK?
>> WELL, OUR COMMITMENT, AS
YOU'VE HEARD PRESIDENT BIDEN
STATE MULTIPLE TIMES, ARTICLE 5
IS IRONCLAD.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN MY MIND
THAT THE UNITED STATES AND, IN
FACT, ALL NATO ALLIES TAKE
ARTICLE 5 VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT IT, AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE,
IN RECENT WEEKS.
THE ALLIANCE WELL BEFORE RUSSIA
STARTED THE WAR IN UKRAINE HAS
ALSO HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT CYBER AS A NEW DOMAIN FOR
THIS ALLIANCE.
WE FORTIFIED OUR CYBER DEFENSES
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF SCENARIOS THAT
COULD INVOLVE IN THE FUTURE
EITHER AN ARTICLE 4 CONSULTATION
OR AN ARTICLE 5 RESPONSE.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO WALK THROUGH
HYPOTHETICALS.
WE'LL HAVE TO TAKE EACH SCENARIO
IN TURN.
BUT I DO NOT DOUBT THAT IF AN
ALLY WERE TO COME FORWARD AND
INVOTE ARTICLE 5 AT THIS
JUNCTURE, THAT THE ALLIANCE
WOULD BE READY TO RESPOND AND
TAKE ACTION.
>> ARTICLE 5, OF COURSE, BEING
IF O